[Music]
welcome to the broken heart gallery Lucy
do you think you want to try getting out
of bed today we're getting smell
complaints from the city have you just
been masturbating and braiding your hair
for three weeks my vibrator will never
break my heart well it will break your
vagina Lucy listen we're in completely
different places you need to get a grip
he's with someone else now how do you
get over someone
what loosely joint less silver Prius but
also I have had the worst night of my
life this isn't a lift this is my car
hello I'm sorry no I'll cancel you're
not a doll so who are you my name is
Nick okay good night thank you can't
have a good relationship because you're
constantly mourning the old one you keep
something from every relationship at
least get rid of the X in the Mobilio
Lucy but also Nick you just magically
show up everywhere are you stopping
[Applause]
the car was just pregame this is where
you actually murder me
I'm trying it into a boutique oh so you
see this time it's the only thing I have
left from my last relationship why don't
you leave it here a nail perfectly
placed you look at that like art in a
gallery I can help with the hotel in
exchange for galleries ice cores we
could use the help you start tomorrow
get us the coffee nothing with actual
dairy ink it's really sensitive and it's
Tommy hey Nick can I come in
how did you get in here your roommates
and we're sharing something and you are
not wearing any pants so stitches this
map was here this morning
yep this is amazing there are broken
people out there like me let go and move
on is this the brick we're in the right
place welcome and ready to hand it over
it has an odor we're in business baby
love makes you do crazy stupid
irrational things remember me what's
this guy doing here guys
[Music]
welcome to the broken heart gallery
heartbreak is the loneliest feeling in
the world and the truth is it happens to
us all I think you should put your penis
in his vagina oh I should put my penis
in his
[Music]